[Musik]
guten abend hier ist heute plus mit
unserem live stream ich freue mich sehr
dass ihr dabei seid das neue semester
ist gerade gestartet und tatsächlich ist
das in deutschland in den meisten fällen
immer noch so dass das portemonnaie oder
auch der bildungshintergrund der eltern
entscheidet wie der karriereweg der
kinder aussieht also wenn die eltern
keine uni besucht haben
dann tun die kinder das häufig eben auch
nicht was die gründe dafür sind und wie
man das ändern könnte darum soll es
heute gehen und ihr könnt natürlich wie
immer mit diskutieren und eure fragen
oder kommentare einfach hier unten in
die spalte posten und ich bin hier heute
nicht ganz alleine
bei mir ist famila borchers von
arbeiterkind.de und freue mich sehr dass
sie heute hier sind
frau borchers bauarbeiter kind.de helfen
sie vor allem jungen menschen die eben
die ersten in der familie sind die sich
entscheiden ein studium aufzunehmen wie
läuft die arbeit da genau ab genau also
wir unterstützen und motivieren alle die
als erste in der familie studieren oder
studieren wollen wir haben ganz viele
tolle ehrenamtliche in ganz deutschland
sind es 6000 in 80 verschiedenen lokalen
gruppen und die gehen an schulen die
machen info-stände die haben offene
treffen wo man hingehen kann wenn man
rat und unterstützung braucht jetzt habe
ich gelesen sie selber sie sind auch die
erste in ihrer familie die ein studium
aufgenommen hat was waren das damals für
hürden den sie begegnet sind und haben
sie damals hilfe bekommen also meine
eltern haben beide auch nicht studiert
das stimmt und bei mir war es ein
bisschen besser ich habe nämlich eine
ältere schwester die hat schon studiert
deswegen war so diese idee zu studieren
schon mal bei mir im kopf dass es eine
möglichkeit ist und ich wusste dadurch
auch schon wie sie sich das finanziert
hat weil wir sind beide von unseren
eltern finanziert worden
zum glück diesen vorteil hat ja nicht
jeder aber ja ich habe vor allem während
und nach des studiums eigentlich gemerkt
dass hätte vieles einfacher gehen können
ich habe mich ganz viele sachen nicht
getraut ich wusste ganz viele sachen
nicht ich mache das immer an dem
beispiel stipendien klar es gibt
stipendien darauf kann man sich bewerben
ich habe immer gedacht das ist nichts
für mich das ist bestimmt irgendwie eher
was für die die
definitiven 10 abi hatten und deren
eltern auch schon stipendiaten waren und
kann mich nie getraut mich darauf zu
bewerben
das ist sehr schade war okay und wir
wollen das jetzt heute noch weiter
vertiefen und wollen auch auf weitere
hürden schauen die es eben in
deutschland gibt wenn es ums studium
geht und da hat nina niebergall mal ein
paar fakten zusammengetragen
gleiche chancen für alle
wenn es um ein studium geht gibt es
zumindest ein paar hürden
studiengebühren gibt es zwar keine mehr
dafür aber einen so genannten semester
beitrag der liegt pro semester zwischen
100 und 300 euro
die durchschnittlichen kosten für ein
wg-zimmer steigen von 363 euro im
vergangenen jahr auf 389 euro in münchen
zahlen studierende durchschnittlich
sogar 650 euro für ein zimmer
man muss ja nicht in die teuersten
städte gehen sagte bildungsministerin
anja karliczek dazu vor kurzem muss man
nicht wenn man an eine der 13 deutschen
exzellenz uni will allerdings schon
die sind nämlich größtenteils in den
städten in den mieten hoch sind
der bafög-höchstsatz ist zwar gestiegen
auf 853 euro
doch zum leben reicht das vielerorts
nicht und irgendwann muss die hälfte des
bafög kredits auch zurückgezahlt werden
der schuldenberg kann auf bis zu 10.000
euro anwachsen
[Musik]
wer an die hochschule will braucht ein
abi oder fachabi der sicherste weg dahin
das gymnasium den schulwechsel sind
kompliziert gehen nur mit entsprechenden
noten abi nachholen ist auch nicht ganz
einfach man braucht zusätzlich zum
schulabschluss eine ausbildung oder zwei
jahre berufserfahrung
[Musik]
dann ist da noch der berühmte nc der
numerus clausus
immer noch sind knapp 41 prozent der
studiengänge in deutschland
zulassungsbeschränkt das brisanteste
beispiel medizin da liegt der nc
zwischen 1,0 und 1,1 79 von 100 kindern
von akademiker eltern studieren bei
nicht akademikern sind es gerade mal 27
von 100 eine neue studie zeigt nicht
akademiker kinder trauen sich ein
studium oft nicht zu
sie fühlen sich von zu hause weniger
unterstützt und sehen größere probleme
ihr studium zu finanzieren
darüber wollen jetzt natürlich weiter
sprechen chemielabor just von
arbeiterkind de was sind dann so aus
ihrer persönlichen erfahrung auch durch
ihre ehrenamtliche arbeit die
hauptgründe warum so wenige schüler aus
nicht akademikerfamilien sich
entscheiden
ein studium aufzunehmen also zum einen
fehlt es ganz oft an vorbildern wenn man
aus einer familie kommt in deren noch
niemand studiert hat ist das nicht die
erste möglichkeit die man sich so
überlegt für seine zukunft weil dann ist
das sehr weit weg
die uni in einem ganz anderen stadt
anderen bundesland teilweise man weiß
auch gar nicht wie es geht
wie kommt man dahin wie soll man sich
entscheiden was man studiert wird macht
das überhaupt sinn
es gibt ganz viele vorurteile ich glaube
da kennen wir alle
etliche wie der taxifahrer ich habe
politikwissenschaften studiert das habe
ich auch immer zu hören bekommen ja und
vor allem ganz großes problem ist dass
man nicht weiss jemand sich sein studium
finanzieren kann und diese unsicherheit
natürlich dazu dass man nicht da hingeht
und sagt ja ich möchte studieren ja das
kann ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen aber
jetzt gibt es ja in der
schland bafög wir haben ja quasi ein
system dafür warum hilft das nicht warum
bringt das nicht mehr an die unis also
bafög ist an sich schon echt toll und
wir empfehlen auch immer dass man auf
jeden fall versuchen soll bafög zu
bekommen und den antrag stellen soll
das ist nämlich eigentlich gut dass man
nur maximal 10.000 euro dafür
zurückzahlen muss und in der sehr
passablen rate aber für familien mit
einem geringeren einkommen ist es glaube
ich schon großes ding was einem angst
macht weil es ist ja doch ein darlehen
und dann schickt man die kinder quasi
zur uni und dann machen wir gleich
schulden ist jetzt nicht unbedingt das
was man sich für sein kind zu wünscht
glaube ich und tatsächlich auch glaube
ich einfach eine bürokratische hürde das
ist gar nicht so einfach so ein bafög
antrag auszufüllen oder genau da
scheitern auch ganz vieler ich sag
scheitern aber es ist ja nur würde
einfach es ist sehr schwierig sehr
langwierig ich habe den abt aufgestellt
hatte große probleme damit muss nun
einmal zur bafög beratung wieder gehen
ja und die teilweise die eltern sind ja
auch überfordert damit sie kommen auch
tatsächlich fragen zum bafög
vielleicht können wir da ein bisschen
tiefer gehen drauf eingehen zum beispiel
bei youtube wird gefragt wie viel
prozent des bafögs muss ich zurückzahlen
und ich würde es einfach mal erweitern
innen wie viel kann ich daher bekommen
und und dann ja wie viel prozent muss
ich am ende zurückzahlen muss wirklich
alles zurück nein ich habe ja nicht wie
genau es ist gedeckelt also bis zu
diesem 10.000 euro
das heißt wenn man 20.000 euro quasi vom
bafög bekommen hat ein budget bekommen
hat muss man nur 10.000 euro
zurückzahlen das geht auch erst ein paar
jahre nach dem studienabschluss los wenn
man im job hat und dann auch in
moderaten braten und ich glaube ohne
dass man zinsen bezahlen das erklärt
auch noch das dalí information ist und
hier kommt eine frage ich glaube weil
sie gerade schon das thema stipendien
angesprochen haben das ist ja im prinzip
auch im bereich finanzierung von cw bei
youtube worauf muss ich achten bei
stipendien wo finde ich infos also
definitiv bei arbeiterkind.de wir haben
bereich studium finanzieren
daher bieten wir auch ein überblick über
alle stipendien die es gibt mit
interviews von stipendiaten so dass man
kleinen einblick hat und dann
wie immer es gibt so drei kriterien wenn
man sich für ein stipendium bewerben
möchte das ist einerseits natürlich die
leistung also man muss schon ganz okay
noten haben also ich sage jetzt nicht
mal muss definitiv nicht die 10 haben
aber man muss schon ganz gute noten
haben soziales engagement ist
aufgefordert und hilft einem da sehr
viel weiter und dann natürlich auch dass
man passt zu dem jeweiligen
begabtenförderwerk dessen stipendium an
haben möchte okay wir sind schon
mittendrin bei den finanzen und es gibt
ja eine belastung die wurde abgeschafft
und zwar die studiengebühren die muss
man jetzt zumindest für das erststudium
in deutschland nicht mehr zahlen
aber es gibt tatsächlich die idee sie
wieder einzuführen warum genau das kann
man es jetzt mal an aufgaben aber können
nachgelagerte studiengebühren eine
möglichkeit menschen ein
damit so das war der oecd
bildungsdirektorin tatsächlich haben wir
schon ein paar kommentare auch daten zu
diesem vorstoß bekommen hier schreibt
zum beispiel mario bei facebook bildung
muss gratis sein und bei twitter
schreibt stefan wie machen das denn die
niederlande oder dänemark soweit ich
weiß bekommt die studentinnen da sogar
geld fürs studium ohne etwas
zurückzahlen zu müssen
und ich würde einfach ganz gerne die
frage an sie weitergeben was halten sie
von seiner idee für die qualität jetzt
wieder studiengebühren zu zahlen selbst
wenn man sie nur zurückzahlen muss wenn
man auch wirklich viel geld verdient
also ich finde das schwierig ich denke
das stellt eine weitere hürde dar
schon alleine wenn man sich überlegt ob
man studieren möchte oder nicht wenn ich
weiß was ich später definitiv was
zurückzahlen muss ist das vielleicht ein
hindernisgrund vor allem wenn man aus
einkommensschwachen familien kommt ich
glaube diese menschen werden dabei nicht
bedacht wenn man solche aussagen trifft
ja und dann muss ich auch ganz ehrlich
sagen also das sind ja die
studiengebühren
dazu müssen manche dann ja auch
definitiv bafög bekommen das muss man
auch nach dem studium zurückzahlen
ich sehe das irgendwie ein bisschen
schwierig und von meiner persönlichen
warte jetzt auch sagen könnte ich mir
persönlich nicht vorstellen
hier kommt tatsächlich auch noch mal
eine frage zum bafög and daher und zwar
unter welchen bedingungen kann man bafög
bekommen
also es gibt eine einkommensgrenze wenn
die eltern zu viel verdienen dann ist
man nicht berechtigt ja das muss man
ausrechnen lassen also das kann man
jetzt so pauschal nicht sagen wieviel
das ist meine empfehlung ist halt dass
man definitiven antrag stellt guckt und
das fahrwerk ist dann ja auch
gestaffelter es kann sein dass ich 50
100 euro kriege oder 500 euro das kann
sehr unterschiedlich sein höchstes genau
da bis zum höchstsatz der liegt genau so
um den dreh also schon gar nicht so
wenig geld eine frage mal in eine etwas
andere richtung und zwar schreibt julius
studieren doch schon so viele leute man
sollte er die ausbildung fördern und
tatsächlich haben wir hier auch schon
genau an dieser stelle mal einen live
stream dazu gemacht wie wichtig
eigentlich ausbildung sind und wie toll
sie sind was wir zukunftschancen sie
bieten
warum fokussieren sie sich so aufs
studium weil eigentlich eher die
ausbildung ja auch eine tolle option und
wenn auch viele fachkräfte gesucht genau
wir sagen ja auch gar nicht dass jeder
studieren muss oder wir sagen ja auch
nichts gegen ausbildungen an sich ich
finde das super ich bin ganz doll
einfach nur dafür dass jeder für sich
eine eigene entscheidung treffen darf
was er mit seinem leben macht wo er
hingeht was von beruf ausübt ich bleibe
gerne bei mir also wenn man mir gesagt
hätte ich muss jetzt eine ausbildung
machen und keine ahnung handwerkerin
werden wäre so wo ich sehr unglücklich
glaube ich damit geworden als auch dann
der kunde der meine handwerksleistungen
in empfang nehmen muss weil das nicht
gut geworden wäre
also muss man ja auch irgendwie der
neigung dazu haben und ja es ist eine
persönliche entscheidung finde ich ganz
schwierig da auch so pauschal zu sagen
ab jetzt dürfen nicht mehr so viele
studieren oder so und es geht ihnen ja
auch bei arbeiterkind.de um die
chancengleichheit einfach dass jeder die
chance haben sollte zu machen was er
möchte
haben sie das gefühl dass die politik
dass die unis dass die schulen die
probleme die es da gibt erkannt haben
ich glaube es hat sich in den letzten
jahren schon etliches getan
es gibt viele neue programme dazu es
gibt studien berufsorientierungstage an
schulen
ich habe auch in rheinland pfalz jetzt
gemerkt dass die hochschulen ihre
ansprache verändert haben dass sie
besondere stage oder kurse bieten um
alleine dieses ganze wohl dinge was ist
ein pro seminar ist ein hauptseminar das
den erstsemestern mehr zu bringen
ich glaube da hat sich schon einiges
getan aber die schwierigkeit ist ja auch
immer die zielgruppe also die
arbeiterkinder
mit den programmen dies für sie gibt
zusammen zu bringen und das versuchen
wir ja auch so ein bisschen wir sind ja
diejenigen auch die dann sagen okay du
hast probleme mit den bafög-antrag okay
bis hierhin kann ich dir mit meiner
erfahrung weiterhelfen und ab jetzt gehe
ich mit dir gerne zur bafög amt und
unterstütze dich dabei dafür gibt es ja
auch überall den fachstellen aber
manchmal weiß man nicht wo sie sind und
traut sich nicht gibt es in irgendeinem
bereich wo sie sagen würden dann müsste
sich auf jeden fall noch was tun da gibt
es einfach verbesserungspotenzial
also ich glaube da liegt noch ganz viel
potenzial in den schulen weil ich denke
dass diese studien berufsorientierung
wirklich sehr sehr wichtig ist vor allem
wenn man irgendwie in die oberstufe
kommt und dass da viel mehr wirklich
auch noch über die ganzen
finanzierungsoption gesprochen werden
muss und es ist ja auch nicht nur so
dass man sich nur für ein studium
entscheidet oder nur für eine ausbildung
sondern man kann ja auch eine ausbildung
machen und dann später in seinem leben
zum beispiel auch noch mal entscheiden
zu studieren und wenn man das aber
irgendwie alle schon mal in der schule
gehört hat stehen einem ja irgendwie
vier weitere möglichkeiten noch offen
und kann weiter denken also es klingt
als wären wir schon auf einem ganz guten
weg aber als könnte sich trotzdem immer
noch was tun und es bedanke mich ganz
herzlich dass sie heute hier bei uns im
studio waren und natürlich bedanke ich
mich auch ganz herzlich bei euch fürs
zuschauen fürs mit kommentieren und
diskutieren den nächsten live stream
hier den gibt es kommende woche am
dienstag und ich würde mich natürlich
freuen wenn er dann wieder dabei sein
[Musik]
und wenn euch dieser stream gefallen hat
er aber noch mehr über das thema
ausbildung erfahren wollt dann klickt
doch mal hier rein da ging es nämlich
genau um das thema oder aber ihr schaut
mal in diesen live stream rein da ging
es um die schule und ob sie reformiert
werden muss oder falls ihr keinen
einzigen heute plus live mehr verpassen
wollt dann lasst doch einfach hier ein
abo da
[Musik]